okay let's do Friday feedback and uh
it's I know many of you wrote to me and
said David what is Friday feedback going
to be like this week after what happened
last week and going through the hate mob
that came after you well I I'm not going
to make this all negative there were
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of disgusting hate messages
including many anti-Semitic but what I
do want to tell you
is that there is a movement that is
insisting there were no such hate
messages there were no anti-semitic
messages or anything and you can
sometimes see them quite literally next
to anti-semitic messages for example
user Shane used the anti-semitic meme
6 million which of course relates to the
6 million Jews killed in the Holocaust
and they love to reference like should
have been more or whatever right six
million so this is another one of these
anti-semitic messages next to a message
that says there's not a hate mob after
you
there are just thousands of individual
people that heard your comments and
found them disgusting really and why
does that then necessitate making
horrible comments about the Holocaust
it's sort of difficult to understand but
many other fascinating messages on the
substance
of preventing mass shootings and
reducing gun violence we got a great
comment on YouTube which reads David as
a veteran of law enforcement myself and
gun owning individual while also being a
Christian father of two
don't let Republicans drag you down the
rabbit hole they intend you to do so
when engaging you your list of ten is
quite honestly very good these are ten
policies to reduce gun violence I laid
out what I would add is specifically a
sliding scale fee and structure that
low-income Americans do not get
financially discriminated against when
following the list of ten ah so this
might be
the training scales for in the cost of
training and Licensing scales for income
I I think I get the idea and a very
interesting idea for sure
Henman left the message and says David
I'm a rock solid Centrist with not much
of an appreciation for left or right but
you are one of the very few leftist
commentators I watch consistently
because of your balanced calm collected
demeanor when tackling subjects hold
fast against the fascist hordes of
Republicans and their extended members
we're behind you all the way to defend
your free speech not right wing Define
free speech I mean freedom of speech in
the traditional sense of the word before
it was hijacked by the right all the
best with much love for the UK thank you
and lots of Brits by the way weighing in
recently which I very very much
appreciate
sharielle said by going after you they
move the Target off of them for doing
absolutely nothing to stop this horrible
epidemic that only happens in our
country bless you David I'm so sorry
you're having to go through this yeah
you know uh there must not be anything
we can do to stop the scourge of gun
violence
say people in the only country where
this is regularly happening are we
really that willing to give up without
trying almost anything it's really
pathetic on the issue of thoughts and
prayers
uh very interesting comment the
Congressional this is Riley the
Congressional chaplain said it was time
for more than thoughts and prayers
does he get threatened you're in the
right David yeah and in fact you know
what's been really interesting since the
blow up last week
is that all sorts of other the prayers
Aren't Enough did they not pray
correctly or hard enough sort of stuff
dozens at least of relatively prominent
people made similar statements there was
one in the Boston Globe and others
none of them generated any controversy
any controversy okay then we're moving
on to some other issues Jason commented
on Facebook David underwear Pacman I
don't even know what that means instead
of reviewing polls maybe you should look
at the actual statistics of illegal
immigrants crossing the border why do
they always put the wrong border border
like a boarding house rather than the
U.S Mexico border Jason says it's in the
millions and the highest ever because of
Biden's policies how can you even try to
defend this topic there is no border
again wrong border b-o-a-r-d-e-r but
merely a fading Line in the Sand
remember a couple things on that number
one
they are stopping people from coming in
oh the border is clearly open because of
all the people that border patrol is
stopping wait so
it must be closed then because they're
stopping people that's number one number
two we know a lot about the surge of
attempts under Joe Biden it started to
increase under Trump as covid waned
Mobility resumed and people started
again trying to come over the Border in
greater numbers they act like we don't
know that there are simple explanations
for most of these things let's now go to
the subreddit El Deus t
wrote Marjorie Taylor Greene says we
need more good guys with guns I think
she's right but how do you become a good
guy with a gun introducing the good guy
with a gun certificate pass the mental
assessment pass the background check
pass the gun safety course
congratulations you're now a certified
good guy with a gun now of course I
would go further
you get yourself the required the the
liability insurance that should be
required in order to have firearms you
are regularly retested and undergo uh
regular psych evals
you were limited in terms of high
capacity magazines based on your age
it's quite an extensive list
um but certainly we are nowhere near
that at this point in time continuing to
talk about firearms
this is this is an interesting message
question from a non-american
why are Americans so obsessed with guns
why do you need them and why are some of
you against restrictions some people
don't even acknowledge the problem I
mean what do you expect there have been
more mass shootings than days in 2023 so
what can be done
armed teachers as was proposed blame
things that have nothing to do with it
trans people video games porn Etc
or ban on some kind of weapons like
assault weapons yeah this you know this
person got downvoted down into a a hole
in the ground but they're absolutely
right and it's it's interesting there
are right wing pro-gun people
who bristle at the idea that
Europeans might tell us what to do with
guns well we should look at it a
different way we should say people from
countries that don't have this epidemic
of gun violence are shocked and
horrified by what's happening in the
United States maybe we should consider
whether they have something to offer and
this is part of the problem you know as
when I was on the pbd program Patrick
Bett David's podcast and I explained
under Trump
Global opinion of the U.S and of the
presidency was in the toilet and
the response when they can no longer
deny the facts is to say why do we care
what other countries think of us if
other countries don't like us if other
countries are scared of us that means
we're doing the best possible thing we
can for Americans and of course that's
obviously not the case in so far as we
live in a globalized world we're not
this isolated country we're not an
island economically and and literally
we're not an island
we actually do depend on other countries
for so many things and so this idea of
what do we care what they think it's
predominantly an idea on the right and
it's extraordinarily short-sighted
um and unfortunately that's the issue
right oh my god look someone someone
from a country that has no gun violence
has the audacity to say what the hell is
wrong with you people in the U.S yeah
that should really make you think oh wow
you mean this is optional it doesn't
have to be like this
give me a break guys all right and then
more um superficially there was a poll
done on our subreddit what's your
favorite nickname for Ron DeSantis the
options were Rhonda sanctimonious tiny D
meatball Ron Gay Ron which I don't even
understand deep State Ron or something
else
overwhelmingly our Reddit audience
prefers meatball Ron as the name for
Rhonda Sanders I have to tell you I
don't really love it
I don't really love it and I know that
Rhonda sanctimonious is a problem
because many
um Republicans wouldn't know how to
spell sanctimonious nor what it means so
that one's problematic I still like
wrong death santis wrong death scientist
but it's a little tough to say
uh open to ideas this guy may not even
end up running so let's wait and see
before we subject him to a permanent
nickname all right keep those messages
coming you can email info
davidpackman.com you might post to the
subreddit and it could end up on Friday
feedback you might make a comment on
YouTube or send a tweet or God forbid
make a Facebook comment any of these
things could end up with you in Friday
feedback we have a tremendous bonus show
for you today I will be away the next
few days and be back with you next
Friday we will have a mix of guest hosts
including producer Pat
and others I think people will like it
if you hate all of the guest hosts
you'll be furious if you like one of the
guest hosts hopefully there will be a
little something for everyone next week
alright everybody so I'll see you then
on to the bonus show onward and upward